this is a production of Cornell
University thank you see a very generous
introduction and thank you all for
coming it's great so over the decades
I've been astounded repeatedly by the
discoveries that reveal layers of
sophisticated mechanisms that have
evolved to regulate transcription of our
genomes the transcription needs to be
orchestrated at our 20,000 or so mRNA
encoding genes but also at the tRNAs the
ribosomal RNA genes the long non-coding
RNAs the divergent transcripts that we
now know are associated with many
promoters and enhancers regulatory
enhancers this pattern of transcription
is not static in cells but responds to a
spectrum of signals including those
developmental signals that take us from
a fertilized egg to an adult or a seed
to a plant signals that occur in
response to changes in nutrition or the
environment and of course changes that
occur in response to disease so this
regulatory specificity relies very
heavily on a large number of short DNA
sequence elements that interact with
hundreds of factors transcription
factors protein factors either directly
or indirectly and some of these sequence
elements reside in this region very
close to where the gene begins
transcription starts called core
promoter these elements interact with a
set of general transcription factors
that direct polymerase to the point a
proper point of initiation
additionally there are elements that
reside further upstream and provide a
chemical complement for the binding
of regular other regulatory factors
these elements and the factors can
sometimes be in large clusters that can
reside large distances from the position
of the of the gene
sometimes in over a million bases away
and still influence the transcription at
the gene target rather dramatically
now it's was thought initially if these
regulatory factors might affect the
recruitment or the activation of
polymerase directly by direct
interactions but more often than not we
now know that there are Co regulators
often multi subunit complex --is that
that the regulatory factors interact
with be they nearby or at enhancers
these come in several flavors some of
those types of of Co regulatory factors
are the mediator which is xx some
subunit complex that were different
factors and plug in their other subunits
then interact with the polymerase itself
there are hats histone acetyl
transferases modified chromatin there
are remodelers that can push nucleosomes
around and and so the lot of these
subunits are part of co-regulators not
only influenced polymerase in its
activity the recruitment of polymerase
and its activity but they can also
influence the chromatin structure making
it a better or worse place for
transcription and finally there are
insulators these mysterious still
mysterious components that restrict
where enhancers broadcast their signal
to you don't want genes activated
willy-nilly and the insulator helps
prevent activation of improper genes and
also I think helps direct the enhancer
to its proper target so in addition to
well to understand regulation and how it
works mechanistically we meet each and
all of these elements and factors and
their into play but we also need to know
what steps in the transcription cycle of
rate-limiting well what are the slow
steps that are accelerated by regulatory
signals and there are multiple points in
the transcription cycle from chromatin
opening to the
initiation complex formation initiation
promoter proximal pausing release from
pausing productive elongation
termination and finally the recycling of
the polymerase to another round of
transcription and their transcription
factors associated with the DNA near you
know either nearby or enhancers that can
influence this process and influence any
of these steps in principle although it
seems like the early steps in
transcription are where what primarily
regulated we over the years became
fascinated or something some would argue
obsessed with with this phenomenon of
promoter proximal pausing which happen
later than what textbooks tell you
regulation where regulation should be
happening and and it involves after
polymerase initiates we find that
polymerase has moved to a few tens of
bases to a pause site and can hang out
there for some period of time getting a
proper signal then the polymerase can be
released into productive elongation okay
so let me just blow that area up a
little bit you can just see it a little
more clearly here there are there's
pausing taking place where there are
specific factors involved thirteen
complexes know from the SIF that help
stabilize the pause there's probably
interactions between a polymerase and
the general transcription factors that
brought the polymerase there that
probably we think keep the polymerase
from is from from readily leaving locus
and helping to stabilize the boss and
finally there's probably some component
of regulation at some of the pause sites
there you do the barrier caused by
nucleosomes so upon activation of genes
we we have other you know factors that
can bring in a kinase was rather famous
kinase they're rather a lot of major
changes that take place but one of the
most significant changes is the
recruitment of a PT FB kinase which can
phosphorylate these pausing factors and
the polymerase itself causing no to
leave the SIF to be transformed to an
elongation factor and
polymerase now to change its
modification state he can then take on a
new entourage or factors that help it
with its movement through these vast
distances through the genes and
chromatin but also coordinate the
transcription with Koch inscriptional
RNA processing ok so shortly after
arriving at Cornell back in the Dark
Ages and 78 I started dreaming about
ways of dissecting how eukaryotic
mechanisms working and and and I thought
it would be worth looking in the natural
context many people were doing a strict
biochemical approach money well I was in
a biochemistry section that really like
pure proteins and I was come work on
dirty also methodologies and do AI do
biochemistry but I thought this would
complement the traditional biochemical
approaches where people were purified
all the components involved in
transcription and then trying to
reconstruct the process in a test tube
and so over the years our laboratory has
emphasized an embarrassingly simple
strategy it's simple-minded approach of
simply taking live cells observing them
perturbing them and then reabsorbing
them ok and in our reasoning is that you
can look at genes and genomes and
transcription factors and the polymerase
the machine of transcription itself and
the nucleosomes if we could look at
these at the highest possible resolution
both spatial and temporal we might be
able to learn something about
transcription and how it works at least
put some limits on models that we're
considering and then we can perturb the
this process either by turning on or
pressing genes and response of specific
signals but we could also make mutants
and transcription factors and do RNA i
or drugs that inhibit particular
components RNA aptamers that might
interfere with macro molecular actions
or use of de grande to get rid of
proteins and thereby perturb the process
in a very specific way and then reabsorb
as soon as possible after the
perturbation to
see what the immediate effect the
first-order effect of these
perturbations are now we can't always do
them these essays immediately after with
a lot of these perturbations but some of
them you can't so the outline of the
talk today is that we went try and cover
the key chock as a model system and we
start off an optical view it'll be easy
to easy to take I think for most people
it's it's always nice to have movies and
pictures promoter proximal pausing is
the second part you'll see this is a
critical step in expression Drosophila
melons very broadly a critical step and
finally we'll do a genome-wide analysis
of transcription regulatory mechanisms
and for safa but also mouse and human
and and drill down a little bit in terms
of mechanism
okay so heat shock response so we picked
the Drosophila system as a model I
picked this early on going Dave hug
misses lab it was the reasons where the
genes are robustly activated many genes
over you know induced 200 fold you can
be a sloppy biochemist and still get a
decent result the response is rapid
happens within tens of seconds it's a
synchronous activation so you can watch
things as they as they happen as
function of time and see as factors get
recruited and machinery goes through the
gene and that set certain limits on to
what those factors might be doing the
principles and underlying mechanisms are
proving to be be general much more
general than I expected and finally Paul
Dean chromosomes of flies and certain
tissues provide a unique amplified
signal and resolution to look at the
chromosomes and look at active
transcription as it's happening so the
heat shock response we've learned a lot
about this in in unand deuced cells
you'll see evidence that this polymerase
already present on the unenthused
promoter not on the gene body but on the
promoter is of work from the honda lab
shows that this drift is know from D si
F associated with the stabilizing that
paused polymerase the general
transcription factors there there's a
Gaga factor that we
you'll hear more about there's a master
regulatory protein factor that doesn't
associate very strongly with the
unenthused gene or edit seat rock
elements but upon heat shock it trimer
eise's and binds very tightly to the to
the activated jeans or enhancers that
are nearby the genes and this recruits
the PT FB kinase which then allows this
pause polymerase now to escape very
rapidly once every six seconds so that
polymer aces are stacked on the gene
about as tightly as they could go in
response to each other so that's the
model and let me just start by going
through an optical observation of how
this how these genes operate this was
facilitated as I mentioned because of
polity in chromosomes these chromosomes
in these in the salivary glands these
chromosomes are I've undergone many 10
rounds of duplication so now we have a
thousand chromatids and they remain
aligned in an interphase extended state
and they take on structure that we can
see here with bands and into bands very
characteristic you can know where you
are on the chromosome what low sign
genes in the LX to and they cut these
chromosomes come from these salivary
gland cells that when we break open the
cells and spread the chromosomes you now
have these dead chromosomes that you can
look at which have been very valuable
here's a mitotic chromosome on their
same scale so you can see these are
really giant wonderful structures that
was fascinated by these immensely when I
started working in Drosophila I stole
him actually and and so in a
collaboration with watt Webb's group
number of you may remember his great
contributions to optical science here in
Cornell we had a joint student Jay G
Yahoo we decided it would be interesting
to take a look at the the polycon
chromosomes using two photon laser
scanning microscopy a technology they
had working and it and later on that
week he came back with these pictures of
obstacle sections taken every half
half microns sections through uh
salivary gland and we could see going
from one end to the other you get this
fantastic view and notice that you could
map begin mapping particularly
chromosomal sites even in this
three-dimensional structure so this
optical sectioning approach worked
pretty nicely
you could identify specific loci which
meant that you could in principle track
the recruitment and dynamics and
interactions of proteins like gfp-tagged
proteins that specific native lo site in
real time in living cells and the
operation can be done with lasers this
two-photon laser scanning but we can
also get a comparable results and faster
with a spinning a state-of-the-art finit
spinning disk microscope and so Katie so
back and and Buckley went down and
collected a lot of data of this sort and
and what we use in this is we have to
match lenses one at twenty two degrees
one one at thirty seven the Heat's on
temperature and and you can then make a
variety of transgenic fly lines we made
a variety of lines that have GFP and RFP
tag transcription factors and and looked
at the various combinations so first at
22 degrees you take optical stacks of
the green and red channels to get two
proteins map simultaneously and then you
can shift the lenses and he capacitor
via winds is such that we know from
direct measurements that the salivary
gland increases temperature in about six
seconds so you can begin immediately
taking watching the time course gene
activation caused by this warm lens that
activates gene expression so let me just
show you a set of movies that are
synchronized here that have we can watch
each arc factor Paul - Pete FB kinase
the famous kinase I mentioned to you
elongation factor SPD six and a
topoisomerase one all of which get
recruited upon each are two major heat
shock low site we're gonna follow a
couple of major heat shock laws are the
ones that have the hsp70 genes there and
so let me start the
movie and then let's stop it really
quickly yeah so here is the view at 18
seconds so there's already a signal that
begins showing up with the master
regulatory protein heat shock factor so
it's it's not there at the beginning
right or very low at the beginning but
upon heat shock it gets recruited
saturates with about in about two
minutes
then Paul too starts coming in and then
along with PTFE kinase and then these of
thirty elongation factors he has just
plotted out the results from many many
nuclei and actually multiple salivary
glands showing the standard error so
it's a highly reproducible highly
synchronized process hsf saturates by
two minutes followed by polymerase and
PTFE than the other factors and so from
this kind of analysis we know that the
activation is different nuclei and
polythene cells a synchronous hsf is
rapidly recruited to heat shock low-side
within 20 seconds and saturates by two
minutes and then it's followed by this
paul ii and PTFE kinase and finally this
shows that transcription factors are
assembled on these heat shock genes
rather than heat shock genes being
transported to some factory as a some
models profess that you move genes
around to places that are transcribed
instead we think at least in these
systems that that you assemble the
factory at the side of the gene so part
two here we're going to investigate
promoter proximal pausing okay and we'll
start by examining the very early
evidence biochemical evidence for
pausing that got me into this got our
lab into this problem of studying this
type of transcriptional control that was
not appreciated at the time so the first
experiments that led us to the idea i'm
gonna go over for experiments extremely
quickly so you can they're published a
long time ago so there it's want to read
more about it please do but
we just give you the essence of these
experiments there's a UV chimp
experiment this is a cross-linking
immuno precipitation was worked by Dave
Gilmour was actually the first of these
cross-linking new precipitation
experiments later became chip
experiments and chip seek and other
things but this was a precursor of those
kinds of experiments than Bartkowski
adopted adapted it told us we looked
decided to look at RNA polymerase itself
before and after heat shock waves we
thought that'd be a good way to develop
this technology before he chart
polymerase covered the entire gene but
in the unenthused gene polymerase was
also given a signal and by doing
restriction digestion and look probing
the DNA that copra CIPA tates when we
have two cross-linking and Amira
precipitation we're able to pinpoint
that polymerase to between minus 12 and
plus 65 it was right at the start and at
high concentrations we estimated one
polymerase per gene what's the status of
that plumbers could simply be bound to
the promoter no nuclear went on
experiments done by an rugby showed that
that you could block new initiation with
high concentrations of salt or a soccer
seal and and release this polymerase
into into elongation and a nuclear run
on experiments you can make that
polymerase move and incorporate
radioactive nucleotides and those and we
could see that those polymerases map to
this same region precisely where they
map was map but was done by Eric
Rasmussen where he fished out these RNAs
and sized them and then finally we
checked in vivo by completely orthogonal
method using permanganate that's
impregnate which Maps single-stranded
T's in these bubbles and we could see
that there were hypersensitive T's
associated with the promoter region even
in non heat shock cells and so all of
this data points to this Klem race in
this model I've shown here has engaged
in transcription made a short RNA of 20
to 50 nucleotides depending on the gene
and it's and it's caused and it can be
made to transcribe in the presence of
Sarkis island or high salt that removes
some of the we
extract some of the barriers that keep
it boss so so these targeted studies in
in the 80s and 90s were kind of ignored
I would say in early stages and that was
because the the field was focused on
yeast as a model system in transcription
which does not show posny and we've gone
back with some of our genome-wide
methods now and show the east
sacrifices of his hair does not show
concept but in the mid 2000s with 2000
around 2005 we were developing for some
very sophisticated people were
developing sophisticated genome-wide
methods from that being polymerase chip
chip experiments were being done where
you could chromatin IP and then probe
these microarrays to cover the genome
and an experiment and some of those
techniques basically we'll see were
replaced by more sophisticated
observation methodologies and one of the
early experiments by being rendered on
in a human lung fibroblast line IMR 90
showed that a ribosomal protein gene
that there was plum races piled up on
the promoter now this is a gene that you
theoretically I mean that we knew is
expressed and so these these reads in
the in the gene body were real and but
we were I mean I most people were
surprised that there would be so much
polymerase sort of piled up on the
promoter if they were simply
transcribing this gene and but this was
blue reminiscent of the paused
polymerase we saw in hsp70 except was
centered right at the start site rather
than being displaced downstream and a
number of other labs were also able to
see these this pilot polymerase on
various promoters and various systems in
drosophila and and in other human cells
work from rick young's lab karen Adelman
and Mike Levine and so we wondered if we
could evaluate whether this polymerase
was a pre initiation complex that is
simply bound or was it paused and and in
the original papers it was interpreted
to be a pre initiation
Lex but we wondered if we could
contribute to this process of of
characterizing these genies polymerizes
on promoters genome-wide by developing a
new method leighton core who is a
extremely talented read student at the
time decided to take on this project of
developing something that we now call
grow seek global run on sequencing and
and the idea is simple you know you if
you isolate nuclei you have polymerases
on genes or some of them at the pause
site some of them on the gene body the
idea is to let those polymerase is run
on in the presence of nucleotides in
particular a nucleotide that has an
affinity tag like bromo UTP there are
antibodies to bromo UTP that you can use
them to fish out what we call the
nascent RNA so you'll run on you get
these bromo use incorporated and then
you control run on hundred bases you can
then isolate the RNA base hydrolyze that
down to a hundred bases so that you can
map precisely where the polymerase was
and this is followed by you know these
affinity purification x' at each step of
the library preparation there are three
purifications and spike in controls tell
us that this is about nearly a million
fold purification of the nascent RNA so
it's very clean source of mapping where
polymerase is precisely and make a
library and then you sequence heavily
and so this was off first
look at this remembered this arriving
one night or one afternoon and it was a
disk full of things on a disk and we
were trying to figure out what how to
count again look at what what this was
telling us by the end of the night
fortunately had a Josh waterfall here
was a physicist who could handle this
kind of thing and by the end of the
night we had these browser shots we were
very very excited and here's the pattern
of transcription of genes you can see
genes going left to right are shown in
red right left or in blue we can see
this pattern over this two point five
mega base region you see the genes stand
out very nicely and we could get a
close-up view by expanding this little
region here and we can take a look at a
single gene and we did this in welding
fiber blast
experiment that being rended will the
same cell line that building ren used
and his bing Ren's data showing the chip
chip results here's the the grow seek
results and we can see that that is a
striking peak of pause bloomer eyes just
downstream from the transcription start
there's another pause going in the
opposite direction that surprised us
it's turned out to be general polymerase
is going the other direction the sum of
the two gives us polymerase that's
centered in the transcription start so
it didn't look like it was paused in
this case but indeed it's caused in both
directions home race and so this was a
surprising feature of the architecture
of mammalian promoters and indeed its
general we can see and there's meta gene
analysis were lining up genes left to
right here and we in you can see in the
red direction we're looking at the
transcription of the gene there's on
average very striking pausing taking
place this is gene body levels and we
see this upstream anti sense
transcription even if we remove any
upstream genes and this is just a
feature of promoters so a majority of
polymer area promoters show pause paul
ii in both directions and we also looked
in drosophila and we see a similar
pausing going on striking pause genes
here some genes don't show pausing but
the majority of greater than seventy
percent of genes show some significant
causing in drosophila there isn't
divergent transcription at promoters
drosophila is a little smarter than we
are i think and they may send polymerase
in the correct direction we can talk
about at the end if you're interested
how flies are so smart okay so just to
reiterate what these these patterns are
so if this green is the density of
polymerase we see that there's a pile of
polymerase at this cause site so way we
interpret that is there there are
factors that's recruit the polymerase
with this big arrow showing with
recruitment sufficient the release and
productive elongation is less efficient
the small green arrow and
we have a pileup of polymerizes here and
what there is some gene body level that
we you can detect and then when a gene
is activated maybe new factors bind and
bring in this PGP kinase and allow them
the increased escape release into
productive elongation and this gene body
level can go up now we were curious and
I should I should add that there are
these very specific inhibitors to the
kindness ptb kindness and we were
interested in you know what fraction of
the genes are are dependent upon this PT
FB kinase this cause and release step
and so IRA's Yorkers in Mouse ES cells
then decided to add this p JP kinase
inhibitor and and and look at what how
the pattern is the normal pattern of the
gene what would happen if we now block
this with flavored peridot how will it
change this pattern of transcription we
see here we're looking just reads in the
know flavored period all case there's a
pileup of polymerases each one of these
lines represents a separate gene you can
see the pile up of polymerase is in both
directions and upon flavor at all
treatment we if we block the release we
should see the gene body go down the
pausing perhaps go up and indeed this is
what she saw if we look at compare the
50 minutes relative to know flavored
period all the change that happens
here's a log 10 scale here we can see
that gene body goes down dramatically on
all genes and was pausing goes up on
most cheese and the same is true for the
anti sense orientation and here's just
an example gene this gene we wouldn't
call as paused because it not obvious
but when you add flavor pyridyl and
watch with time you can see that the
clip the transcribing polymerase is
clear and they clear in this wave you
can actually measure that rate of that
wave movement and get elongation rates
4,000 genes at a time by this method and
in bow
we can now see that this gene piles up
polymerase at the pause site so and in
fact you know virtually written 95% of
genes behave in this way where they have
to be going through this they seem to be
going through this
pause release step even if the pause
isn't detectable so this is a general
mechanism okay seclusions for r2 is most
mammalian drosophila genes exhibit
promoter proximal palsy and all active
genes undergo will pause release that is
dependent on this peach FB kinase the
last section we'll go through are you
with me are you hanging in there okay
fasten your seat belts so we want to now
look at because what can we learn from
this beyond what I've just told you and
so Fabiana Duarte decided to extend this
and Chris awful looking more broadly at
the heat shock response and to do this
we we also made use of a technology that
was developed by a rotating grad student
is now professor here hojun quack where
he took gross leak and made it and
provide a base pair resolution developed
it to a base pair resolution so
precision run on sequencing or pro seek
the way this works is that we
incorporate a instead of a bromo you a
biotin NDP and that chokes the
polymerase let me just back up let me
just back sorry let me just back off a
little bit oh okay we're already there
so what happens is the biotin gets
incorporated in that chokes to
polymerize basically if you're only
buying two nucleotides present you had
one by it and so that marks the three
prime end of where polymerase was and
then you can put linkers on and and in
sequence and that as you sequence from
the three prime end you get the the base
pair precision where the active site of
polymerase is density of polymerase
genome-wide genome-wide and procede
features are very much like grow seek in
and I'll just reiterate these that we
can get a distribution of
scription regret engaged our a
polymerase route the genome he's bride
kinetics snapshots that are not affected
by the background of the accumulated
mRNA one can measure gene expression by
mRNA but if you want to see changes that
happen you have to wait for those pools
to change and instead you can look
directly right at the gene and see what
happens in a minute or two by these
methods to assess the the changes that
are either up or down in regulation
it's the strand-specific assay it's
highly sensitive there's a dynamic range
of nearly six orders of magnitude its
base pair pro seek now differs from grow
seeking that its base pair resolution
and it's more robust than easier so if
any of you have tried grow seek and you
said I'll never try this again try Pro
seek and there'll be newer methods
coming out that we're promising will be
a half-day protocol don't don't hold me
to half date but that's that's what some
of former students arguing okay so so
the hope was that by using Pro seek it's
high resolution and sensitivity could
provide a very fine grained panna
panorama of the changes in transcription
across the genome in response to
regulatory signals allowing insights
into the steps in transcription that are
regulated so we wanted to look at heat
shock genes and he chart response and
watch the whole genome as it changes
right and so we did took Asafa Lascelles
cell cultures did a heat shock and then
took samples at 30 seconds 2 minutes 5
minutes 10 minutes 20 minutes and then
did prosy replicates we did replicates
of course and this was work Fabiana door
duarte with some help my gerton we see
these good high correlations between
replicates we can then begin looking at
the difference between the the zero time
point to non heat shock in the various
time points here to see when differences
significantly occur and we can see that
by 5 minutes there are some differences
that begin to occur by 20 minutes weeks
have many hundreds of genes in pink here
that are activated many thousands of
genes that are down regulated and here's
just
examples of the kinetics changes and we
see this increased transcription within
the course of this 20 minutes on the
upregulated gene you see with comparable
kinetics a down regulation of
transcription on those genes that are
turned down and now so the major heat
shock genes that we were all interested
in shall show pausing and and and we
find that the level of pausing is
generally high on the heat shock
activated genes so we were wondering
what is what are the factors that cause
that pausing to set up the pause begin
with and one of the factors that jumped
out at us was gah-gah factor which we
had previously previously shown was
associated with activated genes as did
lien lab in gilmore lab and but it was
not only and was rich certainly on HSB
70 but it was also rich on other paused
genes generally and when we look at
where gah-gah factor is on the heat
shock activated genes we do this
analysis as a where do we find a gaga
factor binding site bye-bye Gaga factor
chip signals that is the real binding
sites where does it whether they occur
relative to the transcription start well
they occur be largely before the first
hundred bases upstream and so we see
that this 70 percent of the genes have
Gaga factor associated with them of the
activated genes and we have to go much
further out to find them in the case of
repressed or unchanged genes if we look
by just a meta gene analysis where the
Gaga factor is and how abundant it is in
these various classes we see on the
activated genes its high and just
upstream from the transcription start so
75 percent of the activated genes seem
to have this Gaga factor bound but is
this related to Gaga factors role in
causing and each honk activation the
test that more directly we did a one of
these perturbations where we cabana did
a Gaga factor RNA I compared it to a
control lac Z plus and minus heat shock
and then did pros
in all samples and the knock down those
deep work that's shown by this
quantitative Western and and we can get
different classes of genes out to I want
to focus on is the is this red class
where we see we look at the gaga factor
the lack Z our nai ratio on the gene
body that is where has Gaga factor
knockdown led to a decrease in gene body
transcription you see that in red and
these are genes that are show decays
transcription but also show also have
Gaga factors associated with the
promoter however there is a purple class
where Gaga factor is bound but there is
but these genes these act each arc
activated genes don't show any decrease
they don't care about gaga factor and so
we have these two distinct classes those
that care about gaga factor for
expression there those that don't and we
can now look at how is that related to
the pausing that's caused upon gaga
factor knocked down if we take these
gaga factor dependent heat shock
inducible genes shown in red here we can
see that we can see that there's that
that in the gaga factor RNA i knocked
down we we have a decrease in in pausing
dramatic speakers opposing if we look at
this other class the purple class upon
gaga factor knockdown there's no change
in pausing so and we can see this in
browser shots as well here's a case we
have the control we see the pause
polymerase gaga factor knocked down we
lose the paused polymerase control we
see gene activation upon on heat shock
but we failed to see that heat shock
activation and so GAF is needed for
activation on those genes where gaga
factors also needed for palsy and and
there's this independent class where
gaga factors now we're pausing nor
transcription depends on on gaga factor
so something else must be substituting
for that
but let's first deal with how Gaga
Factor is working there was a studies in
the past by Carl whoo that showed that
there were associations of Gaga factor
with a remodeler a nucleosome remodeler
which made some sense
so that remodel is called nerf so the
idea being that maybe Gaga factor
interacts with nerf and that clears open
a promoter allowing polymerizes to enter
at this very early step to create the
recruited polymerase and the pause site
consistent with that recent studies by
by Julius Judd a new student and the lab
has shown that by Chip seek or a related
version of that assay called cut and run
we can map polymerase on genes and we
can see where the Gaga factors located
and we can see then where that nerf
tends to co-localize with with that so
consistent with the model we find nerf
localizing with Gaga factor in Devo we
then tested the effects of a gaga factor
knockdown genome-wide on nucleosomes
are we clearing nucleosomes with Gaga
factor and if we knock down Gaga factor
we see nucleosomes filling in and so to
do that we can map where nucleosomes are
with this enzyme called microcon plays
digests the way the DNA that isn't
protected by the nucleosome and if we
know take that DNA and do paired-end
sequences from each side we can get the
position of where every nuclear zone is
in the genome and it does get a measure
of nucleosome occupancy
well nucleosomes are tend to be depleted
at promoters and you see that in two
classes this is the control knockdown
with lack just a lag see where we see
those that show reduce pose at pausing
still have this open promoter those that
are unaffected by the gaga factor
knockdown are also behaving similarly
but if we now knockdown Gaga factor what
happens is nucleosomes fill-in they fill
in over
the promoter region so Gaga factor seems
to be needed to keep this region free of
nucleosomes so in the model
here's we have factors we have this open
promoter Gaga factor nerf opened the
promoter allowing polymerase to create
the paused polymerase bond heat shock we
now have the polymerase firing OHS f1
binds brings in we think PTFE kinase
allow the nopd epi kinda allows the
firing of polymerase and we get a full
response in the gaga Frank the depletion
we blocked the process in an early step
in that nucleosomes can fill in on these
promoters block formation applause bloom
rice and these genes are no longer
activatable now that i mentioned that
there are promoters that are independent
that are good gaga factor independent of
causing and they show association with
the second factor m1 VP they've been
characterized by Dave Gilmour and and
indeed the enemies are dependent on m1
VP for both causing and heat shock
activation so there are two different
proteins that can set up the pause and
and and and act as we think to allow
than the activation so why pause you
might ask and what's what's all this
wasted effort yeah one reason is we
think is Gaga factor while it helps keep
nucleosomes off a polymerase is a great
foot in the door of chromatin keeping
this region open and indeed Karen
needleman's lab has found that the
polymerase itself if you disrupt it you
can see nucleosomes filling in on many
promoters as well and and this keeping
this open may be very critical in early
development especially in flies we know
where genes are turned on very very
rapidly in very specific stages and
Levine
Mike Levine has shown very nicely that
this is very important and it's very and
all these genes that prescribes this
early embryonic development showed
striking pausing and and require that
pausing for their effect
and another reason I think we have
pausing is is because it gives us two
steps which to regulate gene expression
so we have this Gaga factor working at
this first step allowing the recruitment
by opening up the chromatin and once
polymerase is is recruited we know it
moves very quickly to the pause site we
don't see initiation being rate limiting
and and then a second factor heat shock
factor we postulate then has the ability
we know it has the ability to bring in
PT FB and that influences the second
step of pause escape
pause release so we causes the
phosphorylation of these components and
now polymerase can release this gives us
two different factors that can can
operate in a synergistic way on on an
event that certain advantages getting
high dynamic range but also a way of
interpreting regulatory signals and
integrating those signals to give a
specific kind of response so I think
that's why you might be having factors
working at distinct stages but is hsf
one really working at this stage and so
we've examined HSF the dependent he th
are activated genes looking at their
response in a controlled knockdown Lexy
we see before he chunk we get this
pattern and after he chart this set of
genes shows on average this increase
transcription as you'd expect me he
charging now if we knock down HS f1 this
pausing is still the same but we see in
Drosophila and we see this decrease in
gene body and we interpret that to me
that HS f1 is working at the second step
of releasing the polymerase into
productive elongation if you block it
you don't have HS f one but knock it
down you can't do that second step okay
so historically you know we this has
been an area where a lot of attention
has been focused for regulation we think
that there are really two major steps
step of recruit
once recruited polymerase moves very
quickly to the pause site
this is regulated by factors like gaga
factor then we have release of pausing
that's regulated by other kinds many
many kinds of transcription factors
including heat shock factor it's this is
general we've seen this in mouse and
human cells and and I'm gonna just skip
this next bit and go right to the to the
last little bit hang with me we may have
a only a few minutes for questions no I
can't
well we'll skip the very end bit I'm
sorry I'm sorry for the guys who had
doing the abdomen technology we don't
quite have time for that anyway takes a
full hour okay so we look now in Mouse
and humans behave very similarly you
know the gene body on heat shock we see
look at its fold change on genes we see
this their their increase and these are
hsf one dependent genes that have HS f1
bound to their promoters and we see that
in h SF 1 - - knockout of 8 of this
master regulatory protein we don't see
this activation of transcription so this
gene body transcription needs HS f1 we
can also look at the pause region pause
region in mammals also goes up
unlike cassava and and it's independent
though however of HS f1 and and so our
model is this that that upon heat shock
we we have this increase in release
that's H s f1 dependent so now we flood
the gene with polymerizes and then we
have an increase somewhat the increase
of paused polymerase formation but
that's HS f1 independent and so this
this happens at promoters but it also
we're seeing that there are enhancers
that are also activated I mean not all
keechaka activated genes have HS f1
bound close to them some cases there are
HS one dependent but they're the HS f
must be acting at a distance because
there's no H s f1 bound near it
so we
know that HS f1 is part of enhancers and
we can find some of the we can find
these globally by looking in nan a chunk
and each honkin scene which with these
these sites of transcriptional
activation we know that enhancers when
they get activated it's another story
but when answers get activated they they
show increased divergent transcription
much like we see on mammalian promoters
HS f1 is associated with those activated
genes here we're just looking at the
changes in gene body transcription gene
transcription and those that tend to go
up in heat shock and to have HS f1
associated likewise the transcription we
see at enhancers is often associated
with hsf one but there's a lot of grey
dots here which represent cases where we
see increased transcription but no HS f1
and the model I want to leave you with
here as is the following so we have here
genes the majority of transcribed genes
are turned down in response to heat
shock so we have a just massive
repression of thousands of genes and
it's repressed at the step of pause
release so just just like activation is
influencing pause release the the
inhibition leads leaves us with the
pause polymerase and the polymerase is
that are transcribing clear and enter a
pool now those that are primed for
activation response to heat shock after
heat shock HS f1 binds and we and we see
the increased transcription and we think
this pool of polymerase is that's coming
from these mammalian often very long
genes lots of plume rays start filling
in and hope the induced genes stay
active we look at enhancers we see
increased transcription upon heat shock
and some of those are HS f1 bound and we
see increased transcription but there
are others that show no H s f1 there
that are that are also show increased
transcription they have lineage specific
factors they have factors there but they
don't have heat shock factor there and
these go up we think because of mass
action we have all these polymerases
being contributed from the
pool of repressed genes that now are
filling by mass action and we want to
test that hypothesis so I'm just going
to say that we've been working for 25
years on RNA aptamer it's trying to
develop these as ways of interfering
with macro molecular interactions
because most of biology is driven by
large macromolecular contacts and and
and and if we can get big inhibitors
that could interfere with protein
protein interactions of protein nucleons
right protein nucleic acid interactions
and we have the power to really begin
testing a lot of our models much more
rigorously and these after is you know
could be very useful as as inhibitors we
select RNA aptamers you can envision you
could block one surface of a protein
without destroying the protein and have
the potential act quickly disrupt macro
molecular interactions and potentially
have a high success rate I just want to
say that the way you get after MERS is
by a process called seelix which I'm not
gonna have time to go into but basically
you select for binding and then reselect
for binding and and do a 8 to 20 cycles
of this and you burn out a graduate
student and and and but in the end
you'll get an after with high affinity
for a target and so the past few years
do Loeser and and our Harold Kraig heads
group collaborating to to improve all of
this so we've improved both the RNA
library we have a library about 10 to
the 16th and m7 teamers now it's really
really good we improved partitioning
approaches which I really won't go into
but you can see now we can scale up to
something like 96 of these at a time our
goal is to start turning these out and
massive ways on targeting transcription
factors and other factors of all sort
and finally bar coding in Illumina
sequencing it takes the expense out of
characterizing you know 96 of these at a
time if one wanted on 28 at a time and a
single lane so doing this we're
targeting our major factors and and judi
jee rahe has recently had some huge
success with the SIF after an analysis
by hozier
in that we can have a napkin or the
binds very tightly we know where the
region were it does bind and so we can
then show collaboration with Dave
Gilmour that these the this absent
interferes with the ability of this DSi
F this pausing factored in to interfere
with the binding polymerase here we see
a band shift showing the binding of the
SIF and the fact that an optimal will
block that even if added after and then
lastly last slide here I'll show you is
last data slide is that there's we now
express these in cells we can see a
control Optima shows this pausing in his
gene expression transcription
right-to-left
this is left-to-right and blue and we
can see that this is reproducible upon
Gaga factor knockdown excuse me upon
after addition we see a decrease in
pausing and this is reproducible in this
replica it's just one case there's
another case this is even more dramatic
change loss loss of the pause site and
it's reproducible in replicates and we
see many genes change during twenty most
of them show this decrease some show
shifts or deep increases but also shifts
and pausing as though the pausing is
disrupted at one side it may be piling
up at another we're still an early
analysis of this and I just want to say
conclusion that the transcription
factors can act to establish pause
polymerase or release pause polymerase
Gaga factor I can first HS f1 and acting
later suspect this is a general model
most active enhancers are divergently
transcribed the massive key track down
regulation releases pol ii that loads on
promoters by mass action feeding both
the activated stress gene and I think
priming the response through to
normality your you're holding the
promoters open you're holding the
enhancers open by this polymerase
filling and at the promoters of both
enhancers and from and and gene
promoters then RNA afterwards I'm
arguing with hope will serve as large
drugs that will be general allow us to
interrupt transcription in vivo and I
want to thank all people
group and especially the Saints who were
responsible for this particular work and
not that the others of sinners doing
different projects okay thanks for
attention
I'm sorry went over quick answers the
post-fight direction right yeah that's
honest because of those or just happen
yeah so there's yeah there's are their
core promoters for both of those in both
directions and you'll find them at both
promoters and enhancers and mammals in
Drosophila you you you you have more
elements that contribute to orientation
on promoters and so promoters tend to
fire the polymerase in one way though
the factors that regulate tend to be
between these transcription start sites
in fact we think enhancers both in
mammals and Drosophila and we see
enhancers have this pattern we think the
enhancer is defined by the pause pause
region which has the core to core
promoters and a cluster of transcription
factor regulatory binding sites and we
think that's the unit structure a basic
unit structure of enhancers yes why
doesn't he's do this well it's found
another way to do it
not all yeast don't do this it turns out
palm B has something that resembles this
but there's no no in yeast
there's no Nell in plants we looked at
plants by the way plants you've probably
heard the talks given from John Luke's
group I burped oh I think I hope some of
you heard those in in cassava there
there is something looks like pausing
just like in palm be the yeast palm B
sacrum Isis doesn't have it but there's
known elf in either case and so I don't
know if it's a real pause it we know and
palm be our recent studies of that show
that the polymerase is moving more
slowly there's a maturation step but it
isn't a strict pause plan
also have this divergent transcription
at and enhancers it turns out so we've
seen that in cassava and now in corn and
and these are places where a lot of the
critical snips are located
yes great Jeff yeah so I should know
this better is Ani here yeah you want to
answer that question what's that oh you
didn't hear the question so the question
is upon we have been repeating all this
upon repeated cycles of heat shock is
there any adaptation and but but but
this but it it does come back to normal
it comes back to this to the non heat
rocks they pretty quickly and pretty
completely except for a few things that
are kind of important I could go into
more detail but what is it the Apatow
sustains and to be primed what so much
is retained higher okay so I'm yeah if
you want to I'll hang outside the door
people have other questions this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu